[Music]
this talk I want to share with you our
attempts to automating data science
workflows within P VBA and we are a
speed set the data science branch off of
the Banking Group B VBA we are a young
company we exist since four years ago as
Pete said we are 50 60 people working in
Madrid and Barcelona and as a young
company four years ago we went from
doing zero data science to delivering
big projects into production at the
scale of
vva so we were able to do a few loops of
real projects and growth and we've
learned a few things ok and one of the
things we learned is that the data
science processes or workflow the way of
working also contains some
inefficiencies and we is not so
surprised probably and we actually ask
ourselves whether this can be addressed
with some data science tools or call so
ok so this will sound a bit experimental
and just a caveat here and we have to
get a scientist and data engineers but
so far we've been a bit data science
first ok and this is changing but this
will explain that if some parts of this
slide sound of it experimental to you ok
so as in many other companies the goal
of data science and eat our engineering
teams is reducing inefficiencies in
products or services ok and more
concretely to us it means things that we
can show through real examples so these
are real projects that we've been
working on and where we delivered
something into a product so one of the
first projects as in any data scientist
that goes to a new domain is guess what
recommender systems right so we've been
working a few years in recommender
systems the interesting thing in
recommender systems for banking is
you can do things like here customers
through the app could receive discounts
and retailers who are also customers of
the vva you know retailing or vva
enterprise can connect to their
dashboards and it would be great if
there is a way to match retailers with
relevant customers so with in working on
building recommender systems for that
we've been using standard tools like
collaborative filtering but also easily
we found there's a data engineering
challenge there as we have more than 10
million users and 1 million products so
here in this blog posts you can also
read about a talk we gave at the AWS
summit explaining the details of how we
made this efficiently right and also
behind that work there's even some
research in recommender system that is
going to two conferences so this is
Campbell of end to end project which
have a clear business you know benefit
and which has challenges without the
data science and data engineering level
and when I say that this helps reduce
inefficiencies it's because now it
provides a new way to efficiently
connect retailers and customers which
before was not possible or it had to be
done through other channels which
involves maybe rule-based systems or
expert knowledge right so this is an
example of an inefficiency that is
reduced in the backend we also working
to reduce inefficiencies in the
front-end for customers so I don't know
how your bank displays the your their
website right but since a couple of
years ago we've been proposing to
display the customer expenses in you
know experimental ways or more
meaningful ways and this is an example
where customers can browse their
expenses by categories and navigate not
in chronological order but in let's say
semantic order so this required building
a text classification and transaction
classification system which is running
behind that product that is now
available for
the customers in Spain and we had a talk
at the last spark summit Europe where we
described some parts of that some
challenges and some research we were
doing there in the same way one year ago
or so we had released the forecasting
expenses tool which helps customers it
it alerts customers about potential
upcoming expenses they were not aware of
or they were not remembering right and
this is a machine learning system that
is running behind this product that is
analyzing the time series of customers
and doing forecasts and in this
particular example we are especially
proud of that because it's really a
machine learning based system there is
no single hard-coded role there okay
again this is helping reducing
inefficiencies for customers because
customers can be remembered
automatically or don't need to go with a
calculator and and this is really
helping them okay and just to show you
how complex these projects are this is
not only data science and engineering
but the specific problem of time series
forecasting is actually has also many
open challenges in in in terms of the
analytics or the science and we've been
also working sometimes in collaboration
with universities here in Barcelona to
actual research in timeseriesforecasting
in order to to generate knowledge or new
models that later could be integrated
into the low solutions so this an
example also of research that we
presented recently in the European
machine learning conference okay so
these were three examples and to
interject for the challenging in terms
of data science data engineering even
science and with which were delivered in
some way to the business and the thing
is ok yes we have reducing
inefficiencies but over the years
working in those in the in this context
we also learn that the workflow of data
scientists when they work on these
projects also has inefficiencies
themselves right
and as I said at the beginning I don't
think this surprises you everyone who
goes who is new to the field and goes
into data science creates things like
that right you know cleaning big data is
the least enjoyable data science task or
feature engineering takes 90% you know
all these typical statements right but
the thing is is it true so we wanted to
answer that question and actually we
made the effort to document the work
flow of data scientists in our project
so this is a slide which has been
actually compiled by the data scientists
it's not a communications slide or a
management slide so this was actually
compiled by data scientists who wanted
to make their work fit into the
processes of large corporations like you
know if you have to be compliant with
agile practices how do you mix the two
worlds and and so on so this is actually
how our data scientists describe the
steps they do in their project ok so if
if you in the data science business you
may have similar processes or you could
adapt that I think you would agree on
most of the ordering of starting from
business understanding proposing
analytic approach then doing all the
data work data collection gathering data
engineering feature engineering right
then feeding those features into models
evaluating these models and maybe going
back if the model is not satisfactory
and eventually deploying and later if
you are lucky having customer feedback
which can in turn you know produce other
looks here okay so so this is what our
understanding is from data science
project under sort of complexity in many
places so these are rows here are here
because so data science is a and the
feature engineering is a very manual
process with lots of unknown unknowns
investigating looking at the data
discovering new things and slowly
building the best features for a given
problem right so what question is can we
actually with our data science can we
help improving at least some parts of
this workflow and this sounds as I said
at the beginning a bit experimental but
you know there are people who have
thought about that also in the past and
you know the typical examples like
products such as Google Cloud Auto ml
which is aiming at also like automatic
hyper parameter and model selection or
the teapot open source code where you
can define data science pipelines and
and let a genetic algorithm automate
them or or find good models and on the
right you see a couple of research
projects which are aiming at either
automatic model selection or the one
from MIT which is about finding
combinations of attributes automatically
from tabular data that will be the best
ones for a given prediction you know use
case so looking at this this is a bit
the context of what I was what I am
going to explain I'm going to explain a
couple of real projects real attempts to
increasing the efficiency of our data
scientist by providing them tools that
are created with with data science ok
here I make a parenthesis in these four
years we've also learned that you want
to make the other science more more
efficient a very good way is to also
invest in better engineering practices
and better engineering tools ok and we
are doing that but this is not the
subject of today's presentation but if
you want to discuss about that we are
happy to to discuss and our CTO is also
here who can give you insights on this
on this topic ok but here we are going
to show two specific projects for
increasing data science efficiency
the first one is what we call trying to
back and the goal is to build systematic
baselines to make them available to data
scientists so then they don't have to
start from scratch in every project so
here we meet again our workflow let's
remove a few things just to concentrate
on on the line between the business
initiative and and the evaluation so
when I said systematic baseline what I
mean is the following can we find some
way of short cutting this is there a way
that so that we can save at least at the
beginning save this path here and have
that maybe some set of standardized
attributes under standardized model at
least for a given set of you know narrow
situations where we can do that ok so it
turns out most business initiatives so
the business initiatives can be very
various right and can be a lot many a
lot about many things but the majority
of business initiatives are around a set
of a limited set of entities right for
example Spotify worked with songs and
users ok so we work with users and
products so it turns out in many cases a
new business initiative is about
predicting some property for a customer
in order to avoid starting from scratch
and doing all these paths every time we
could have for instance a set of
standard customer at revealed in a set
of standard models so that at least the
data scientists can go through this path
once and very quickly then maybe learn
something from doing that and yes I
agree then the devil is in the details
and you still have to go through the
other part but at least doing that could
give some benefit right so I'm going to
explain you how how we did that so for
us a systematic baseline is two things
first a generic representation of your
entities of interest and here we started
concentrating about customers as I said
with
most of the business problems are about
predicting a property of a customer for
example segmenting a customer into a
group or recommending a product to a
customer and so on so there you need to
have customer attributes and then the
second part is flexible and simple model
to use with those attributes so you will
have the question like is this possible
do these things exist right do these
generic entity representations or or
flexible models exists well in some
situations yes they do exist for
instance I was reading that Spotify
recompute song embeddings so as you know
embeddings is the ml machine learning
Jurgen technical term for you know a
vector representation of an entity so so
Spotify is using song embeddings Tretton
period so that other data scientists can
benefit from those and use them in their
projects and in general there are many
situations in machine learning where
researchers have found that yes this
generic attributes exist for example in
NLP you can have many NLP tasks I know
if some of you are working in an ALP in
your project but you can work on
document classification or entity
recognition but today a big amount of
the projects using NLP for different
purposes have this pre-processing steps
of computing word embeddings and there
are very standard techniques to do so
okay as you may know work is is a method
to assign a representation of a word
okay here the word is your entity of
interest that then has good properties
to be used downstream in other processes
okay and in one prop one well-known
property of word to back is it will
assign a vector and array okay of
numbers to a word such that if you
compute the physical distances between
the elements of the array and then
project them into some sort of
visualization that preserves those you
would find that related words in meaning
will appear closely together okay and
here
two examples this is some workout we
computed for this presentation and and
here you see there salvation of the
space which contains the auxiliary verbs
there's a region of the space that
contains the you know words ready into
location and so on okay so we want to
get inspiration from this in order to
construct our generic or systematic
baselines in our case it would look like
the translation of the previous idea so
here would look something like that
so you have to start with our raw
representation of the customers then try
to convert this into the generic
attributes I mentioned through some
machine learning method and as I just
mentioned previously you can think of
that or you can interpret that as a
point in a space in some way which I'm
going to detail later and then we found
that there's this very simple but very
effective classifier or in general
rigorous or called nearest-neighbor
regression okay which is flexible enough
to work in every problem as long as you
have enough data all right so let's go
through these steps so first row
representation so bhairav representation
I'm in and this is my definition any
information that you can get from your
data sources using a sufficiently simple
query okay so if it's more complex than
so if the poly needs to be complex it's
not raw data right so here I'm showing
an example where I say give me the
accumulated expenses for each customer
for the last year and grouped by
categories okay and this will be my what
I call the raw data so of course you
could also you could already do
interesting things with the raw data if
you want to segment customers or predict
things but it's always more interesting
to find a representation that captures
some of the semantics
properties of this data for example you
don't know if one category is more
important than another category in terms
of defining customer behavior right or
another situation is that many times you
observe a zero expense and then you
don't know if the customers really had
no expense in that category or it's not
going through your bank right so this
could happen so this is the raw data we
will transform this raw data using a
neural network and that performs
conversion of this raw data to an array
of values that has this property that
two similar customers will be assigned
to a very similar arrays okay so that is
a good property for this a good general
assumptions for whatever machine
learning method you want to apply later
on okay and I will discuss the model in
the next slide but basically you can
understand it as what means two
customers are similar it means you can
predict the expenses of one with the
expense of the other and finally we
found that this is a very good pattern
when you come find that with
nearest-neighbor regression so if you
have enough pairs of x and y meaning of
customer attributes and the label of
your task and you have enough data you
can always perform any reasonable
regression on almost any task right a
nearest neighbor regression was like
saying if I want to infer a property an
unknown property of a customer I find
the most similar customers where the
property is known and then do some
operation like averaging for instance
with our property and this is a quite
generic baseline that we found it's you
know it's applicable to many problems
okay and I recall this may not be the
best solution for all the the possible
tasks and I'm not claiming that so this
is just a very once you set this up this
evidence that can be run very
efficiently in the early stages of a
data science project
regarding how we compute the
representation and here this habit going
in-depth technically but if you're in
machine learning you I'm sure this
concept will be very familiar to you so
we use at the noising auto encoder so an
out encoder is a neural network and as
you know in a neural network and you can
have some inputs here our inputs are
dictionary of raw data as I was calling
it and then it performs an operation
which yields an array of values in
another layer so this array of values is
obtained by multiplying those input
values by some coefficients okay then
you get an add another layer you can do
the same and get another layer okay and
an out encoder is basically a network
that learns we could say it in simple
terms means to predict some of these so
learns to predict the value of an input
given the other inputs okay more or less
this is more true for this type of fault
encoders called the noise in old
encoders so in the noisy old encoders
you artificially put some of the input
values to zero while you're training and
this is simulating the situation I
mentioned before right maybe a customer
had a zero expense in a category but
it's not because they didn't make an
expense in that category it's because
you didn't observe it okay example if a
customer has expenses in garage right
it's almost for sure they have a car but
they may have an insurance with another
bank so your insurance would be zero and
still you would like your methods to
capture the information that they may
have some expenses in car insurances and
this method sorry are able to to achieve
that so it's also theoretically been
shown that when you input these values
the values you have here in this hidden
layer and have the property I'm
discussing before right this is an array
of values that represents your entity
and to similar customers should have two
similar arrays this is what what we are
using
and in fact later we found that a
variation of that called marginalizing
stock the notional turn colors is the
best method to to perform these things
okay here I'm showing after each strain
I will show an example of what is it
doing okay so here the rose corresponds
to customers the columns you see a white
or black square and it corresponds
whether a customer head or did not have
an expense in one of the categories okay
for example one of these columns means
supermarket another column means school
another column means withdrawal from an
ATM and so on right and you see here a
few customers and you see if during a
year they made or did not make that
action and here we have this is not
visible here but we have made a
clustering of those customers and here
each of these blocks is one of the
clusters and to do that clusters we have
left out the hotels category okay to
make that clustering we did not take
into account whether the customer went
or did not go to a hotel now it turns
out when we when we inspect the clusters
that where the travel expense is active
which is I think this red and one of
these one of these columns here
I cannot remember which one it is but so
one of these problems means the customer
had an expense in hotels we took all the
clusters were customers have expenses in
orders so sorry in in trouble and we
found that they do have they appear to
also have expenses in hotels so it has
clustered correctly we infer people with
traveling behavior okay when we compared
to the traditional social demographic
attributes that are used in many in
banking for campaigns or for
segmentation we find that when we
inspected those clusters the clusters
don't have a meaningful interpretation
and this is because two people of the
same age who live in this
post-cold could have many many different
expenses in different categories and
those different behavior so we've
written some of the findings in this
paper here that we invite you to check
if you're interested just to summarize
we did two let's main use cases one was
client clustering so the idea would be
to say to replace the classical
segmentation in the bank by segmentation
by behavior and here comparing to other
methods our clustering quality metrics
improved by 61% and the other use case
was category prediction like can we
predict if a customer will have an
expense in an unseen category for
example will the customer incur in
opening a savings account right and this
could be interesting for recommending
products and again on this benchmark we
had an improvement of 76% with respect
to the baselines so for baselines we use
basins with socio-demographic attributes
also using the raw data without any
processing and this was the summary or
this is still an ongoing project but
internally we are trying to address this
project and align these projects with
three pillars which are research
implementation and product enablement it
means we are taking care of the three of
them at the same time so it's not a
fully results project or is not fully a
development project so as you see there
was algorithmic research here because we
had to find a good way of representing
customers in a generic way which
confirms to the state-of-the-art methods
in machine learning we have implemented
that as a software package which is
available to our data scientists and
we've done it in a way that it requires
like weight training and that it can
work on our own infrastructure
and it's really relatively lightweight
to use and then during the development
of that project we have been paying
attention to two use cases and we were
aligned with some business unit to start
and to have early feedback on whether
this would be interesting for the data
scientists working on those projects so
as I said this is ongoing work and the
main metric here of success will be
reusability right is how many different
projects use that and go down this path
that I mentioned I'm going to show a
second example of a project that we
called automatic modeler I will go much
quicker over this one but then if you
have questions or are interested in
general we can we can discuss later so
the automatic modeler is a like it's a
different situation it's a situation
where you have where you need to
construct and sewins linear and
interpretable models and we've designed
a pipeline to do actually this
end-to-end design of features and models
so that basically data scientists don't
have to do fit manual feature
engineering I mean here you meet the
workflow again as we said there's this
chain from business understanding
through data through model to evaluation
and of course you can never automate
that you can never claim that you can
automate everything here why because
there's a lot of manual work here human
decisions unknown unknowns so it's not
possible okay
but if you reduce if you constrain
yourself to very narrow situations which
you identify that repeat over time then
it's possible that you can identify
specific steps here and propose
automation and this is what happened
with this with this project here so it
turns out in our data science projects
we met very frequently this situation
you need a linear model okay you need
you need to have few variables and you
need that
are inter credible okay so what what
does it mean it means you want a model
like this you know the probability that
a customer buys this product is
coefficient times the balance in the
account plus another coefficient times
the days scenes you know plus product
plus another ratio of this and this
variable okay so you need this for
different reasons sometimes these models
are given to two domain experts people
who are domain experts but not experts
in machine learning so they have to be
able to understand what the model means
also this is because in some cases this
is given by the regulation so the
regulator forces that you have to use an
interpretive model so the situation here
is a data scientist or an analyst put
Explorer many feature combinations start
trying propose a feature combination
evaluated with their model check the
accuracy and invent a new feature that
they think it's meaningful and so on
okay so here we built a pipeline that
will emulate that behavior from a data
analyst and actually will produce models
by itself and has a you know can self
check the quality of the models and at
the end propose a set of a diversity of
models to an analyst to do the final
validation okay and very briefly this is
as follows so typically you have raw
input variables for a customer right
social demographic variables expenses in
categories and things like that right
and we typically start in those projects
with few hundreds of variables then
simulating also what some analysts would
do we perform a variable expansion that
means we convert all those variables to
new variables okay how so we can apply
transformations of those variables for
example it is well-known that when you
deal with monetary amounts the logarithm
of the amount is it behaves better than
the amount so okay let's try a few
functions here logarithm
squares and so on and also feature
combinations like one feature - the
other or Rachel's of features okay
if you threat if you're on cattle and
you have read title forums you will see
that the data scientists really do that
they say oh I found feature three four
seven - feature two eight six is the
best for a predictable feature and so
here why don't we define let's say a
primitive or a dictionary of of possible
combinations and then just compute all
the combinations so we are here that
will produce about 250,000 features okay
and of course most of them are
meaningless we can easily check when a
feature is really not correlated with
the target label with a statistical test
so the next step is a statistical test
where we can reject a 1/4 of the
variables or so or one third and and get
up to 80 K okay and now we have okay we
have variables which are the our
candidate variables but one problem here
is they don't provide a lot of diversity
so many features are very correlated or
mean almost the same so what we do is in
the next step we do a hierarchical
clustering of the features so we cluster
features by the correlation they have
between each other so this produces
groups of features that more or less
mean the same and from this produce
about 1,000 groups and then here comes
now the real step of building the model
with this 100 s or a 1000 clusters we
can select a proxy of each of those
clusters that means a variable that
represents the cluster so that you don't
need the other variables and let's say
you have to pick up to 10 variables of
them which are not so correlated and and
check what is the accuracy of of picking
those in order not to do all the
combinations because it would be
impractical we combine to mechanize one
called one s FS which is a feature
selection algorithm to initialize two
mechanician initialization and to find a
set of
you know possible variables that that
have and that are meaningful and then a
genetic algorithm really does the the
track the selection they select a group
of variables evaluative check the
accuracy then select a different group
of variables based on the previous
result okay so that you don't do
combinations blindly but combinations
guided by what you already know okay
at the end of the process you have
something like that and these are real
screenshot of a UI that comes with this
internal tool okay you have here a table
of candidate models and you say model
ABC you can you can give names to the
models if you want but here for the
example it's just letter names right and
it says how many how many variables who
these models have here from 1 to 9 is
actually let's say it's actually a
single model but all the combination
muddled with one variable is considered
different from the model of nine
variables okay but you can explore other
models here you could see what is the
accuracy of each of these models as a
function of the number of variables so
as if you want to find a good trade-off
right between number of variables and in
the model so the more variables you have
the less interpretable the thing is and
remember you want to apply to a few
features and if you click on one of
those then you can go to specific
metrics like you can get the error ROC
curve for that specific model you can
also see the coefficients of the
variables and then you can go back the
other candidate models select and at the
end of the day this is useful for an
analyst to actually choose features that
are meaningful so the analyst has to
validate whether the feature combination
looks meaningful whether they have to
there are some variables that had
strange behavior or or or things like
that and easil I have from this part but
I can tell you in a couple of use cases
we found a couple of interesting
features that makes sense and that were
not thought
by the analysts in the first place okay
so here I this is finishing the two
examples I had so learnings we made from
that so we thought about designing tools
to make data science projects more
efficiencies more efficient two of them
as I shown one about generic customer
attributes and systematic baselines the
other about constructing models linear
interpretable models automatically so
the experience has been positives so now
we have two real tools which are
available today the scientists and data
engineers in the organization this is
still ongoing work and the philosophies
of it experimental as you see and the
experiment is ongoing as I mentioned the
real metric here is reusability but by
the way we have learned a lot in the
specific machine learning domains we
work with when we worked on that and
before finishing I wanted to make a
reflection here that also this kind of
learning we made from that which is
commoditization of machine learning
algorithms is a reality that means you
can go to Amazon Web Services pay and
you buy the latest time series
forecasting model they have ok or you
can go to to Google Cloud and pay for
auto ml and and they will automate your
hyper parameter search and model search
ok so you can do that but what we
observe is this works well for
mainstream problems right so if you if
you have an image classification problem
within your project so it makes sense to
use one of these generic tools imagine I
want to do I want to infer the sentiment
of a tweet based on the text plus the
image so it makes sense that you pay
from for one of these services or api's
okay but when you our experience and
what I have seen when you work in a data
science team which works at that scale
the number of problems or I would say
the speed at which new problems appear
is faster than the speed at which
at the speed at which machine learning
tools get commoditized okay so these
tools are useful to solve the few
mainstream problems but you always have
a lot of problems where you need your
domain knowledge so that means you will
always need the other scientists or in
other words the people who are most
interested in automating data scientists
are actually data scientists as opposed
to some claims that you can sometimes
read in the press and when you have a
company like BBVA which is such a scale
like 140,000 employees and several
thousands of employees working in
analytics at least this is the
projection for the future there is still
a lot of room for your own projects and
community Ising internally and this is a
buy versus make reflection I always make
when I think about that thank you very
much also thanks to these people who
provided content and if you have
questions or want to discuss any further
I'll be after lunch at the data income
focus hours or you can visit our website
and learn more about our projects thank
you hello hi ha once you have precise
information about people I'm just
curious to know what banks do with that
information so sorry you mean we build
features for customers yes I'm happy to
show you what we do
so this tool set we are offering you a
customers through the PVA up in Spain we
have several tools where you can show
them categorized expenses you can show
them upcoming expenses so this is just
one more use case is and this is
available through the app so if if some
of you are from Spain and our customers
of vivia you will have it we have the
function idea of comparing customers
between each others please also done by
other banks by the way in Europe so you
can compare your expenses to similar
customers right am i spending too much
in this category versus customers who
are like me and the like me can be
defined by custom by generic customer
attributes or it could be defined by for
instance this method III just explains
which captures the behavior better
another example where you use customer
attributes is recommendation
you know recommending products to
customers you know things like that any
I would say by the way you can do I mean
banks have been doing that with standard
set of attributes social demographic
attributes here are here I'm just
explaining a way to get a meaningful way
of computing customer attributes so that
then you can automate all this
recommendation engines
you